rien ne semble avoir changé dans cet
élevage d'huîtres nettoyage des
coquillages préparation des bourriches
entretien des parcs
cette ostréicultrice a pourtant vu ses
ventes plonger depuis le début du
confinement ou 70% de nos clients sont
des restaurateurs donc vous imaginez
bien qu'avec la fermeture à cause du
confinement c'est catastrophique quoi il
nous reste quelques poissonnerie on en a
cinq
c'est très peu par rapport à la totalité
de nos clients à la saison printemps
elle est fichue coup et c'est pas après
on ne refera pas de chiffre d'affaires
le chiffre d'affaires perdu est perdu
un printemps sans relance économique
mais avec les charges à payer
impossible pour stéphanie lefebvre de
mettre son activité entre parenthèses
manga ils ont ils ont travaillé on a
essayé de les travailler au maximum
normalement et effectivement à leur bord
de chars c'est compliqué parce que parce
qu'il faudra sortir beaucoup plus de
sous dans trois mois quatre mois c'est
en moi et là ça va être compliqué parce
qu'on n'aura pas fait plus de chiffre
d'affaires nos salariés sont au travail
et continuent d'avoir les mêmes charges
fixes sans aucun regret on peut pas ne
pas continuer si on ne tourne pas nos
poches
eh ben on aura pas d'huîtres et nos
huîtres de prendront une forme coupant
complètement moche et délirante et le
travail sera pas fait du fait de la
baisse brutale de la demande la
production est passée de plusieurs
centaines de kilos d'huîtres par semaine
à seulement quelques dizaines et pour
limiter les pertes financières cette
ostréicultrice tente de maintenir la
vente directe aux particuliers
ça va voilà en pré commande par
téléphone impeccable
voilà plus qu'à récupérer et déguster et
profiter du moment voilà faut se faire
plaisir par ces moments de confinement
on a fait une ouverture tous les matins
où les gens peuvent venir à l'atelier
soins en précommande et ils ont
précommandé ils arrivent avec leurs
règlements on leur met dans leur voiture
et voilà soi et on a maintenu une vente
comme on faisait être un peu
traditionnelle
à l'atelier comment on faisait avant
pour certaines personnes
nos clients fidèles qui ont un certain
âge mais en fait on a mis en place aussi
des livraisons sur les communes voisines
où on livre tout le val de saire quoi en
fait
satisfaire les habitués en attendant que
les plus gros clients relances leur
propre activité
les restaurants doivent encore attendre
pour être fixés sur leur avenir
vendredi bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie a en effet annoncé que la
date de réouverture des restaurants sera
connu d'ici un mois